how can I forget the first time I was in
a class and there was suddenly the
sounds of these very loud sounding boots
clunking across the floor and there was
a campus policeman standing at the head
of the class and he just shouted out my
last name and he just said come with me
and I was put in the back seat of a
squad car and we went directly to the
city to the police station and the
interrogation room was one table in the
middle of the room and a tape recorder
in the middle of the table and there was
even the light bulb on a string hanging
right above tape recorder I'm sorry this
hasn't happened to me in years right off
the bat they said we know that you're
gay
[Music]
in the 1950s a Florida State Committee
spent years terrorizing LGBTQ people
they stalked intimidated and outed
hundreds and they got away with it what
happened in Florida can be traced to two
things happening across the u.s. at the
time first this was the era of the Cold
War between the US and the Soviet Union
and a u.s. senator named Joseph McCarthy
claimed to have discovered communists
who had infiltrated the US government I
don't intend to ever avoid giving the
names of traitors giving the names of
communist when I discover them in a
parking position one of the images that
we probably still have is the image of
Jim McCarthy standing making a speech
holding up several sheets of paper and
saying I have here in my hand a list of
communists didn't matter of whether the
list was accurate or not but what
McCarthy started did real damage
thousands of Americans ended up losing
their jobs and had their reputations
ruined around the same time the civil
rights movement was picking up steam in
1954 the Supreme Court ruled that
separate schools for black and white
children were unconstitutional
in Little Rock Arkansas preparations
were being made by the school board for
compliance with the court verdict
southern politicians started losing
their hold on a segregated Society it
was out of this that the Florida
legislative investigation committee was
born
their mission was to preserve racial
segregation it was informally called the
John's committee after the influential
Florida State Senator Charlie Jones who
had called for its creation much like
Joseph McCarthy John's made accusations
he eventually claimed that civil rights
groups were secretly backed by
communists there is no doubt communist
people behind a lot of this agitation
they had a chart where they had drawn
lines between all these different
organizations that they didn't like at
the top of their list was one of the
largest American civil rights
organizations they thought okay the best
way to stop integration in Florida is to
try to destroy the n-double a-c-p but
that plan was short-lived at that time
the n-double-a-cp head lawyer was there
good Marshall pretty good opposition
they weren't winning lawsuits against
the n-double-a-cp
the John's committee's plans to fight
civil rights groups was a failure but
the committee still had its sweeping
investigative powers that they can use
to target anyone they just needed a
target back then all of us who were gay
lived deeply deeply in the closet we are
always concerned that someone would find
out well in their minds if you were gay
or lesbian you could be blackmailed by
communists because the Communists could
lure you in and say we're gonna have to
tell everybody you're gay or lesbian if
you don't cooperate with us across the
u.s. local government started targeting
LGBTQ employees and in Washington
Congress began investigating LGBTQ
federal employees claiming that they
were unsuitable for government jobs and
security risks it was a targeted hunt
that became known as the lavender scare
it was in that context that the John's
committee found its new focus to purge
the state of LGBTQ teachers and students
the committee believed LGBTQ students
and teachers were endangering the state
of Florida their new mission was to find
them
so we're in the State Archives in
Florida where they have all the
interrogation transcripts that the
committee conducted over the years what
we found in those files tells the story
of how the committee operated the John's
committee working with university
administrators and campus police
conducted hundreds of interrogations
often in motels with no legal
representation they'd ask questions like
have you ever engaged at any homosexual
activities
do you enjoy normal sexual relationships
with your wife did you ever give anybody
a [ __ ] some interrogations happened
after entrapping people in the men's
bathroom of the County Courthouse an
investigator would place himself in the
men's bathroom adjacent to their subject
they would ask if he wanted homosexual
activity wait for them to reply yes and
conclude this man is a confirmed
homosexual we were a very poor family
was able to enlist in the State
University Gainesville University of
Florida on my 25th birthday
I knew that this was my one chance for a
decent life and this was threatening
everything that I had planned for they
said we want the names of all of your
friends who are gay
and I said I don't have any gay friends
which of course was not true and they
wanted to know if there were any gay
professors on campus I wouldn't tell
them one of the tactics they used was I
came back after summer break and I had a
new roommate one day he came into the
room appearing to be very very drunk and
he was walking around the room taking
his clothes off around the dorm and
started trying to entice me into having
sex with him I grabbed my shoes I got up
and I got out of the room as fast as I
could
some days or weeks later he admitted to
me that yes he was employed by the
John's committee and they had hired him
to see if he could entice me into a
situation it was a
[Music]
it was a low degree of terror at the
University of Florida the committee's
tactics led to the forced dismissal of
at least 70 students and professors the
Florida Education Association had
requested from the chairman of this
committee a listing of any teachers
known to be guilty of this kind of moral
deviation the John's committee destroyed
many of their papers but one undated
memo revealed that they had over 300
pending investigations that had spread
to other Florida universities and grade
schools during the past five years we've
revoked his tickets seven to seven
teachers the committee's tactics
eventually began to attract attention
and then they published a book after
almost a decade of their crusade here's
what finally helped unravel the John's
committee it's known as the purple
pamphlet
this was a report on homosexuality in
Florida that they published for the
benefit of every individual concerned
with the moral climate of the state in
the pamphlet
they used graphic images meant to depict
gay men and they even used sexualized
images of young boys meant to connect
homosexuality with pedophilia and then
on the back of the pamphlet was the
stamp the state seal of Florida so that
didn't go over too well you might
imagine with Florida taxpayers when they
found out this is their money was being
used to produce what most people
considered porn the following year
lawmakers eliminated funding for the
committee and they officially folded
they shot themselves in the foot which I
think is complete poetic justice of
course it's hard to know how many
victims of the John's committee are
still out there many have passed away
and others were so intimidated by their
tactics that they left the state never
to return
like our coppleson these interrogators
the investigators they weren't very
bright people but they had tremendous
power over others over us the bottom
line is I graduated with honors and I
got a job the morning after the
graduation service I was out of town
gone over 50 years later the state of
Florida has yet to acknowledge that the
John's committee did anything wrong it
ruined people's lives in the way we'll
never truly understand as a white
heterosexual Democrat I'm kind of the
guy that needs to apologize for this
currently in the in the State House
that's I've been Jenny a member of the
Florida House of Representatives who's
pushing a bill for a formal state
apology quite frankly we still do not
give equal protection under the law to
the LGBTQ community you can still be
fired in the state of Florida if you are
a member of the LGBTQ community
for now though the full story of the
John's committee and the people's lives
it forever changed remains largely
hidden behind the redacted names tucked
away in dozens of old boxes after all of
these years I still am pretty much a
pretty closeted guy I still shy away
from a lot of social contact with other
gay people because I'm so uncomfortable
being identified as a gay man
for this piece we were only able to
scratch the surface of what was in those
documents at the Florida State Archives
so if you're interested in learning more
about the interrogations or John's
committee meeting notes you can check
out all our scans at the link below
thanks so much for watching and can't
wait to share the next episode of
missing chapter with y'all soon